Is there music?
I don't think so.
Sorry if I can hear my computer.
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
Actually, can it...
Oh, okay, it is capturing on.
Oh, yes.
Hello, ladies and gentlemen.
Ghouls and ghouls.
Welcome to the maid cafe.
A girlfriend.
Girlfriend rental location.
Welcome to the maid cafe and girlfriend location.
This is all that I could rent out on such last minute
notice.
I am very sorry.
It's the 3D stream.
It's not.
It's VR chat.
It's different.
different if it's 3d stream don't you think I would make
like a bigger deal about it also for those who if you don't
realize if you didn't know I had some issues with my with my
VR controllers they are currently plugged up right now so my
limit my movements are a little my limits are limited my
movements are limited um oh gosh and i have a i have uh
what's the words a rental mint push push
oh my god oh my god oh my god real i can't tell if i'm
backwards or not why hold on okay maybe is it backwards for
you guys no okay good Okay, there's no music in here.
I don't think.
There's no music here.
So, uh, here I come, everybody.
To the stage.
The one, the only.
Bird.
Hey, guys.
I just flew in here, and I'm sinking through the floor,
apparently.
Oh, gosh.
tired hello um yeah i'm a little purple what about it huh
i'm a little purple and my arms aren't are tired because my
hands are like this because i'm a ghost uh hello welcome to
um why am i sinking through the floor oh god oh no oh god
now i'm sinking for oh wait that's my legs you can see them
thinking i was gonna do a bit where i was actually sinking
through the floor But you guys just completely ruined it.
You guys just completely...
Completely ruined it.
Oh.
Why is this mic so low?
And huge!
Hello.
Um.
Oh my god.
Even I have to bend down.
Hello.
Welcome to the maid cafe and girlfriend rental.
You guys, I think I'm a little afraid of this place.
Because, uh...
Let me show you.
you also if you can hear if you can hear vr chat noises no
you cannot hold on hello hi hello gosh i'm busting already
um but that's okay busting makes me feel good and you too
apparently Yeah, do you guys like the low poly model?
I saw that scuff word made it and I was like, I want to use
it.
It's so cute, right?
Hold on.
Let me get out of...
I'm pretty purple.
Oh, I'm pretty...
I'm pretty purple, though.
You can see me and my dress.
and my legs my legs my body and such yes and my arms are
like this because I'm a ghost the kicks oh sorry it's still
attached to a cord ah guys let me show you why i think i'm
afraid of this place where are you oh hold on um one second
okay oh oh one second okay can i show you guys i'm turning
you around
sorry for my shaky hands look at this beautiful place um
well look at wow i don't think this is a maid cafe first of
all but the paw print the paw print seats are very cute i do
like those let us let me show you uh the reason i'm afraid
of this place i think so um no no there's a bar they have
some snacks i can't read that but let me show you why oh
sorry i'm struggling to leave oh oh my god no no no no i
don't know if it's copyrighted so why are there these rooms
room suite one room suite two and room suite three not like
it's a sweet but like uh like uh like a oh it's sweet i
might we see but okay let's go to the room suite one
together
well thank you i can't read it though
this looks no good this looks no good why would you need a
bed in a mid cafe
this is so bad what is going on here you get tired no no to
rest in a mid cafe there's only energy there's only energy
there's only moi moi energy coming at you There should be no
resting.
Snake, it's a furry room.
What are you talking about?
I'm going to explore.
I'm going, I'm going, I'm going, I'm going in.
The pictures on the walls make me even more scared.
What is going on in this picture?
And then, and then, and then, over there!
That one too!
why are they kissing does the room smell funny
yes let's go to another place okay I think this place is
kind of scary where should we go the world is our oyster we
can go to McDonald's it's trending right now let's go to
McDonald's everybody
alright Let's see, let's go, McDonald's.
Here we go.
Whoa.
Okay, luckily it loaded pretty quickly.
I'm kind of scared.
Oh, gosh.
What are we gonna see?
What do you guys see right now?
Oh, you guys see McDonald's?
I don't see anything.
Oh, we're here.
We're here.
Where are you guys?
Hello.
oh there
you are hello oh there we go okay wow this actually looks so
nice looks like a real mcdonald's um there's even like a
sign up there you can't really see it up there it's like
serving smiles from the year 3000 that's a little cool oh
sorry see Take a picture of me in front of McDonald's sign.
What am I doing?
La la la la.
La la la.
In front of the McDonald's.
Whoa.
Friend of the McDonald's.
In front of the McDonald's.
Nice.
Minto cute.
Shut the hell up.
What's that over there?
GNC, Verizon, Subway.
GameStop!
And there's a Best Buy right there.
This is the most real American I've ever...
Wait, is that an Olive Garden?
Why is there a...
Why is there a McDonald's when we can go to Olive...
Oh, there's Best Buy.
Olive Garden instead!
Let's go.
Endless bread sticks.
This is a real America simulator, I think actually.
Whoooooo!
Italian kitchen!
Wooohhhh.
Oh, come on.
Excuse me.
Let me in.
Let me in, olive garden please please i need to go please
let me in the olive garden let me let me in let me in please
let me in please oh no oh i know this is probably a little
late but how's the audio and stuff hopefully i'm not blowing
your ears out
Adia is good?
Is it thumbs up?
Sorry that there's no BGM.
Maybe I should have.
Maybe I should have put my own BGM.
What happened to you?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
I couldn't tell you.
Okay.
Let's turn you around.
Back to McDonald's, everybody.
Let's go inside McDonald's, see what they've got.
Can we go to Waffle House per chance?
But also, I want to actually look at this.
What is that over in the yonder?
Over yonder.
Oh, we have a Walgreens.
Oh, it's a Starbucks.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, these are...
What?
With the McMurror.
Huh?
Oh!
Oh.
It's me looking at you.
Look at him.
Me looking at you.
Look at that.
This is a mirror.
This is not me.
The McMirror is so funny.
Can I...
Right.
Whoa!
Wee!
Oh, I think I'm going to throw up.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, no.
Don't ride the Mickey Bear Railway sound.
Oh, shit.
Oh, God.
I'm going to throw up.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, God.
Please, someone help me.
Get off.
Get off, please.
Oh, God.
I'm going to throw up.
Oh, please get me off of this thing.
How do I get off?
How do I get off of this?
I'm pressing everything.
Oh, God.
Oh,
God.
oh god oh oh don't ride don't don't ride it if where are you
guys actually i don't even know where where am i oh there
you are oh nice landing oh gotta work those vr i was like
going i had no control over it What are these guys?
Oh, sorry.
These guys right here.
I can also sit on them.
Oh, no!
Please, God!
Oh, not again!
Oh, please!
Oh, God, I can't stand.
I can't stand.
Oh, oh, God.
Oh, okay.
Okay, it stopped.
I'm okay.
I can stand up.
Hold on.
No!
How do I get off it?
Get me off please!
Why can't I leave?
McDonald's is a dangerous, scary, scary place.
Get rotated.
There's also a slide, I wonder if...
Try the yellow one.
Okay.
Wait, is it different?
Is it different?
Are the different kinds?
red no
no no no okay that's not any different it's not any
different i'm gonna do the slide though will you guys watch
me watch me do the slide okay i'm gonna put it kind of far
so you can see the whole process okay okay actually i'm just
gonna have it look at me oh my god okay watch me watch me
mom watch me go on the side I gotta go on the side okay mom
watch me go on the side how do
I get up okay can you see me oh wait you can't see me hi mom
hi mom here we go oh it says to sit on it okay oh
Did you see me, Mom?
Did you see me go on this?
Okay, hold on.
See, we go on the side.
Right?
Oh.
Yep.
Gosh.
This is the place for kids to go.
This is the number one children activity.
La creature.
She's coughing up blood.
Nah, I'm okay.
Coughing up ectoplasm.
Maybe a little bit.
Okay.
I'm okay.
There's also a drive-through, but we don't have a car.
Unless there is a car there.
I think we should, I think we should, I think we should
steal it.
I think we should steal the car.
All right, follow me.
Follow me.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, where is it?
There it is.
Oh, no, I'm going the wrong way.
I'm sorry.
I'm looking through what you guys are saying.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, I'm gonna pretend.
I'm gonna pretend I, like, broke my foot, okay?
And you're just gonna, and then when they get out of the car
to help me, you, you get in, you get in, okay?
As soon as I'm just like, oh, oh, oh, youch, oh, ouch, my
foot, okay?
I'm gonna make it really convincing, not like that, okay?
Like, really, really, okay, so you good?
You ready?
Don't chicken out on me, rookie.
Don't chicken out on me right now.
Are you good or are you good?
Come on.
That's what I thought.
And don't get distracted by the best spy either.
Okay?
Let's go.
Excuse me.
Oh.
I think I, um...
Oh!
Oh god, what's happening to me actually?
I think I broke my foot!
Oh god!
hurts oh god what's happening to me oh wait i said i would
make it convincing but not like this
oh oh god i think i broke my foot oh god what's happening oh
um can you please help me that's your cue that's your cue
help help please help me please i think i broke my foot i
think my oh my body oh my body oh my body i think i broke my
body oh what's happening oh god oh god oh god Please, oh,
please help me.
Get out the car.
That's your kill.
Please, please let me in.
Please help me take me to a hospital.
I need to use your car.
Please, I can't pay for the hospital.
Give me your four digits.
Give me your car digits and the three numbers on the back,
please.
What are we supposed to do again?
You're supposed to get in the car.
Okay, you know what?
I'll do it.
Uh, uh, uh.
It's so done!
Go, go, go!
Run!
Oh my god, it's the wrong type of vehicle!
I'm in this, I'm in this car actually.
Wait.
How do I jump?
Oh, there we go.
No!
Hold on, you guys are so far away.
Don't leave us to die.
Alright, come on.
You guys gotta use your...
You guys gotta use your little legies, okay?
Come on.
It's okay.
We got another car.
We got one right here.
Oh.
Oh, why am I still so shaky?
Are we okay?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, is everything okay?
I can't tell.
Futurama ship?
this one I don't know what it's going to do to me though
guys I'm kind of scared I don't know what it's going to do
to me oh whoa oh my god whoa whoa
oh my god I'm a scavenger oh my god we can go through the
drive there now everybody oh whoa I'm coming back wait
something just happened where did I go wait I don't know
what just happened what just happened wait where am I at I'm
a Starbucks wait
how did I get the Starbucks oh wait you cut ah
um there were people there there were people there is
everybody okay I just jumped back home I jumped ship I
didn't know what to do I just I just I'm sorry I'm sorry I
didn't know what to do there were people there how am I
supposed to talk
everything's fine you know what we didn't even go inside we
didn't even go inside to them oh man but but but but but I
have a place that I really really really wanted to go is it
okay is it okay if I go is it okay I saw this on I saw it on
Twitter a couple months ago maybe not even a couple months
maybe like a month ago and I was like that's I'm when I do a
VR chat stream I must go there I must the snake what what
what oh my gosh thank you guys for all the donuts too thank
you thank you super chats and memberships thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you oh it's kind of hard to
read a little a little bit so um but let me see lapper style
says it's your birthday on Friday happy early birthday
unfortunately I can't go to off guy but can you bring me
back some chaotic con energy when you come back yes i will i
will be going from the con to japan so it might it might
take a while um probably you know so shadow moses close not
quite not quite not quite wait hold on not
quite not quite shadow moses not quite No, no, no.
And Jago's, thank you for the 10.
Gifted, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Okay, we're gonna go.
And we're gonna explore, probably.
All right, give me a second to pull it up.
I only looked around it a little bit.
Can you hear me typing, by the way?
The ping pong, ping, ping pong.
Ah, here.
Here, here, here.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm,
hmm, hmm, hmm, I wonder
how my controllers are doing.
Not bad, not bad.
But not, I think I can't un, unplug them still.
Okay.
Are you ready?
See it?
Initializing world.
You're in the void.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Huh?
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Sorry, there was a guy over there that scared me.
Look at him.
Wait, can you see him?
That.
That guy scared me.
I thought it was real.
Welcome to Arsenal Gear!
Yippee!
It's the big shell!
Yes, we're here in the big shell and we're gonna go
searching for bombs and whatever else is in here.
Whatever else our hearts desire.
I'm gonna have it not look at me.
I'm gonna turn you guys around.
You'll see him?
That's what I turned and looked at.
That's what I turned and saw.
I was like, I thought that was a real person.
But look how cool it is.
Welcome to Metal Gear, everybody.
You can access Arsenal Gear through Shell 1 Core B2 hostage
room.
Okay.
Yep, totally.
All right.
I guess I can walk through this.
No, I cannot.
I think I can jump up this.
Wait, how do I get around?
Huh?
How do I get through?
The vent?
It's already gonna actually make me crawl!
Here.
Here I go.
Whoa!
Oh, I'm too big!
I'm too big!
Hold on.
Save EE this time.
Okay, don't look at my skirt though.
Don't look at my skirt.
Wait.
Don't, don't look, don't do it, stop!
Okay, hold on.
I have to lay down.
I think...
Is it working?
I can't fit.
You guys, I can't fit.
Um, we're looking away.
I don't want to crawl.
Is there a way to crawl?
Ugh.
I don't think this is correct Unless can I get low enough
Can I get down low enough Can I get down low enough to fit?
Come on Go Mint Go Can I get down low?
How low can you go?
Two, thank you How low can you go?
Can I get down low?
Okay, I don't think that worked Hmm thing there's a floss
emo but i kind of want to try flossing first okay this is
this is me actually trying to floss and
then this is the real floss
oh wait help me i can't stop oh my god
that was the real floss everybody how do i get past here i'm
actually so confused okay let me try in without you guys.
See, this is what's happening to me.
Why can't I get through?
Metal gear?
Eh?
Am I actually supposed to go through here?
Or over here?
Oh!
Wait!
Oh my god.
Oh!
I made it!
Can you see me?
Hold on.
Why can't I go through the...
Why can't I go through the sign?
Wait,
I think I'm stuck.
Wait, I'm stuck, you guys!
I was stuck in the middle of the air.
I'm going to have it look at me, actually.
So I can see what I'm doing.
Maybe.
I actually don't know if you'll be able to see me.
Okay, hold on.
no no no please no no no
wait maybe if i jump here there we go okay okay jump
my oshi is illiterate
metal gear solid two plants chapter one respawn point is
dynamic respawn three times in a to return here you can
access arsenal gear through a show one those settings in the
next room interact to hide it's
all your fault it's all your fault
okay let's go
let's eat my show hold on oh oh my bad sorry i didn't mean
to do that
all right look at this can they open they can oh wait wait
hold on oh my gosh take a screenshot of me in the locker
can you see oh hi mom
Must have been the wind.
How do I get out?
If I jump, can you see my hand?
Oh, you can't.
Ta-da!
Wait.
I'll do a different pose every time.
Ta-da.
How do I...
Wait, hold on.
Let's go, silly, come on.
Let's keep going.
We gotta get the nerd.
Beep-boop!
La la la!
Hocking, hacking, hacking, did you just say nerd?
hacking hacking hacking did you just say nerd let's go oh
let's go where's this oh i think i turned the world sound
off there we go oh my god there's actually ambiance thank
goodness wait i'm gonna fix the camera just a little bit
um oh maybe i shouldn't have it just looking at me the whole
time sorry it's been a long time since I've used a VR chat,
so it's, uh, Hayden!
Thank you for the vibe, gifted!
Thank you!
Uh, one second.
Kind of want it, like, over my shoulder, right?
So that we can walk through this together.
So you can take my hand.
Just kidding, you can't grab it.
I'm a ghost!
Okay.
Say, here we go.
whoa oh this is a work in progress april 4th 2024 that's
what it says here so that remember when i said i saw it
pretty recently that's when i saw it incorrect locker sound
and b1 filtration chamber number two performance
improvements tried to reduce a ram by ram some doors and
warehouse have a wrong way door asset improve world lighting
wow fix seagulls flying add sound add more ciphers.
No, no, no, no.
I'm trying to read it, but my chat is right here, and the,
the, so it's kind of like, oh, more death triggers, respawn
if you get stuck, teleport system, and mirrors, I guess.
For some reason, people in VR chat, they, I can't look at
you unless I turn around.
They love mirrors.
I don't know why, but like, I've been told by people that do
a lot of the air chat that sometimes people will just sit in
a room for hours and just look at themselves in the mirror
isn't that kind of crazy let's keep going thank you oh god
why did i do that anyway settings uh background music oh
yeah let's do that oh i think it's just the ambiance okay
never mind particles I don't see any oh or dance in front of
them maybe real real what does that say what does this one
say real he may real time lights just kidding I don't need
you mm-hmm let's keep going the nerd now here's where we
really nerded out.
Okay guys, I'm trying to get a good angle for you.
Oh my god, mom, I'm on the nerd!
I'm on the nerd!
Woohoo!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, where did I go?
Oh, help me, help, help!
Did you just say nerd?
This is me spreading lies on the internet!
Can I actually interact with it?
No, it doesn't seem to be the case.
Oh, no worries.
Oh, my gosh.
We're going to go upstairs.
I'm so excited.
Here we go.
Beep.
Okay.
Here we go.
Strut a roof.
Oh, I see it.
I see it says strut a roof, but it doesn't show up for you.
guys that's kind of sad i showed it just like how it looks
in the game wow it's beautiful turn around turn around turn
around turn around look at that oh where'd the sun go oh oh
i you can see it i can't see it though for some reason wow
oh oopsie i accidentally went back downstairs mother base it
really looks like a mother base doesn't it hold on my fault
hold on we gotta go I didn't know it was an insta teleport.
Okay, here we go.
We'll go around.
Oh my gosh, it looks so beautiful!
Big shell!
Whoa, and the water and everything.
Wow!
There's even the bird poop!
Wait, you guys can't see it, hold on.
Where are you?
There you are.
Look at the bird poop!
Hold on.
Oh, let me turn off auto-level.
Get a picture of me with the bird poop!
Tee.
Tees.
Moe.
way.
Cheese.
Oh, I almost fell over.
My arm, my leg is being a little funky.
Cheese.
Oh, oh.
How does it do that?
Wow.
Quite a show, huh?
Anyway.
so beautiful that's where Emma died well that's not where
Emma dies but this is where Emma will die cool shall we
continue onward I can see stuff over there oh there's some
ciphers over there and oh wait hold on I forgot to do
something I forgot to do the most important thing gotta put
you back a little bit though I forgot to loony tunes my on
the bird poop okay I was good that was a good one wasn't it
okay that was a good one wasn't it
um how do i want you guys to follow me again we'll just have
you follow my back again okay
all right returning we're going this way there's more the
more bird poop there's more of it right there and there
should be some more over here more bird poop now let's get
inside but we have we can't crawl through there the door is
wide open for us for easy access but can you guys see
through here you can see like um you can see like the pipes
over there and stuff it's so cool right this is how mgs 4
should have been what do you mean can you skateboard around
and vr try scuff word scuff word scuff word if you're
listening scuff word oh my gosh the funniest thing okay hold
on so when i was preparing for um for this stream i asked
scuff word i was scuff that made the model.
So thank you, Scufford!
I...
Oh, you're here!
I have been summoned.
Look, Scufford, if I want to put sunglasses, if I want to
give me some cool shades, but no pressure, you know.
But anyway, last night I messaged Scufford.
I was just like, hey, is it possible that I could use this
model in VRChat for my stream?
I saw that you made it, and it's so cute!
And they were like, yeah!
And then...
Oh, that made a headset.
they uploaded it for me i was so happy it was so nice
because otherwise i would have had to redownload unity and
do all that funny stuff but um but uh they were like oh well
i'll upload it for you and then you can um just grab it from
my private world and i was like cool and i joined let me
show you how i looked oh don't look at me let me show you
how i looked oh did you hear that since I didn't have an
avatar
this is the only one I could find well not the only one but
this is maybe the best one I could find I'm a rat look at me
I'm a rat everybody but um because the model or the avatar I
think it's a little weird on VR chat even if you change of
an avatar to um public it doesn't show up publicly for
everybody immediately and so um and so when they when they
made it public i had to wait but i was like oh no i don't
want you to have to like wait not i don't because they would
have to invite me back to their private world i was like i
don't want you to have to be like oh i'm busy i can't invite
you back to my private world right before my stream so I was
like you know what I'll do I will sit in your private world
all night I left a VR chat pin nice pin what are you talking
about hmm oh sorry I didn't mean to pin it sorry uh unpin
sorry I'm just clip clapping my hands everywhere sorry it
had your five seconds of fame okay i don't even know sorry
who who it was sorry
but anyway um so i stayed in i stayed in vr chat the whole
night and like just as this tiny little rat sitting in this
void world just next to the the thing that would allow me to
change into this into this avatar i thought it was really
silly because i woke up and and i was and i got on my
computer and i tested it out and i was just like oh i can
use the model now and um and yeah it was really silly so
anyway so that's why the controllers were dead no no no i
was on i was on i was on desktop my my vr stuff hadn't even
been hooked up yet so sorry that i pinned you and unpinned
you you probably were so excited you were like what does it
mean Why was I pinned?
And then I took it all away from you.
I wiped out your weird pin.
Anyway, let's keep going.
Wait, what time is it?
Okay, I still have an hour.
Before my meeting.
My very real meeting.
Oh, we're going to strut a pump room.
The music!
And, oh wait.
These are not the zone of the ender's boxes.
Where are those ones?
Oh, that's a...
Okay, yes, I know where we are.
Wee, wee, wee, wee.
There it is!
Hold on.
Bum.
Hold on, I'm going to be really sneaky, okay?
Hold on.
I'm going to crouch down a little bit.
Here, even look at me.
Look at me.
Except watch me be...
Shh.
why
is my butt in the air like that wait don't look i'm gonna
hack but sneaky wait can i sit here no
i'm sneaky i'm sneaking around i'm glad that when i um
oh where are you oh you're looking here we go when um you
guys saw my thumbnail you were like wow it's very uh
bigfoot-esque you guys got what i was going for nice let's
keep going this way oh is the music okay for you guys you
want me to turn it up a little bit what was that noise what
noise
oh why is it so this is not where we came from but let's try
it out strut a roof i think it's just the other side yeah
it's just the other side okay never mind
must have been the wind whoa whoa whoa let's go through here
oh this is where you crawl through the pipes and We have to
get to the bomb!
Oh!
What was that noise?
Can I get in here?
Whoa!
Uh-oh, wait, I don't want to get stuck in here though.
Uh-oh, wait a minute.
Was this a bad idea?
Uh-oh, you guys?
Uh-oh.
Wait a second.
Wait a second, I think we might be stuck.
Uh-oh, wait a minute.
Wait a minute!
Uh-oh.
Maybe through here?
Can I slip through here?
Oh, I hear it!
You see the bomb!
Wait, is that the bomb?
Or is that just a pole?
I hear it though.
Do you guys hear it?
You-you-you-you You guys, I'm stuck!
I'm stuck in here!
For real!
Um, uh...
Who do I do?
Respawn.
Oh, there we go.
Nice!
I want to see if we can get to it.
Oop.
Sorry if I'm going a little fast.
Oh, nice.
Ow.
I actually don't remember where it's at.
There it is!
I see it, I see it, I see it.
I see it.
Mint's back.
don't look okay this is very serious business I will defuse
this bomb
oh wait
what just happened oh wait I changed my chat on accident
hold on what just happened I don't know thank you though
whatever what I don't know why I'm saying thank you.
Diffused!
Good job.
Okay.
I don't know how to get out of here again.
So, uh, we're gonna...
You're gonna follow me.
You're just gonna follow me.
I'll take the lead, okay?
Oh!
Oh, no!
I almost had it.
Okay, nice, nice.
Ha, ha!
I mean I mean I mean let's keep going we're doomed what are
you talking about I totally blew that out are these more
lockers who what oh sorry It has Konami eyes!
They're even in here!
Wait a second.
Can I get a...
Can I get a certain achievement?
Being in there?
Anybody wanting to get the snake beater achievement?
Anybody?
Okay, it's okay.
I'll take the sacrifice.
Good night!
What do you mean?
Ouch.
No, I'm only doing really pleasurable things in here.
Hooray!
I just flew in, and boy, are my arms tired.
Okay, um, I think I used that joke one too many times today.
Maybe.
Uh, wait, one second.
Alright, follow me!
Oh, no, we went this way.
We wanna go there, through the exit over here.
Right here.
Here we go!
A-B, connecting bridge.
Wow!
Wait!
So beautiful!
Wow!
Box time!
Let's keep, let's keep going.
Sorry if you're going through the walls sometimes.
Look, you can see the water!
Whoa!
Don't fall out, don't fall.
What if I do fall though?
What if I do fall?
oops my bad here we go wait what's wrong right right right
wait could you could you see that or did you only see the oh
no you only saw it you only heard it probably it actually
showed the whole menu that was so good it showed the whole
menu and everything it was just like showed like the sorry i
keep forgetting you guys around the side showed the whole
like you die menu and everything what just happened don't
worry about it it's just ghost things you know just ghost
things okay um this way but i'm trying to figure out how i
want the camera to go there we go oh oh oh wait wait wait
wait wait Wait, wait, you must see, you must see, you must
see, you must see, you must see, you must see.
Look, look, look, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my
god, oh my god!
Let's go.
It's trying to be a transformer room.
It's kind of spooky, isn't it?
It's kind of spooky.
Wait, I'm scared.
Wait, but there's no one here.
But me, I'm a ghost!
I'm haunting this place.
Okay, let's go.
MGS2 is looking up.
Whoa, there's so much blood on the ground!
Wow, wee.
Okay, let's go.
Do you think he'll be here?
Oh, yeah!
There's a winks.
There's a wink.
Oh, I hear another one.
Hmm.
Dracula?
No.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, it's your turn.
It's your turn to go in.
Listen, here.
Listen, here, nerd.
Yeah, nerd.
I'm putting you.
I'm putting you in the closet.
Where you belong.
I mean, the locker where you belong.
And you never come back.
out.
You hear me?
Nerd!
Was that enough for you?
Was that enough time?
Was that all you needed?
I feel like you don't need that much time.
Not for you, at least.
What else is in here?
Nothing.
Nothing here.
Put me back in.
What do you think this is?
What do you think this is the the the the b-ball court no
you're getting benched okay one second meop meop meop meop
meop meop follow me oh there's so much blood in here um uh I
sure hope some guys that are um some I sure hope some guys
named or I I don't even know their name.
Some guys that are, you know, allies of this ship.
I sure hope they don't come in here.
They're definitely allies, you know.
Hold on, I gotta actually rearrange some stuff because my
setup is all weird.
Seal Team 10.
Yeah.
Sure hope not.
That would be really...
I sure hope.
I sure hope some guy I sure hope some guy Doesn't sit here
and smoke at all That would be like
Really weird
Oh my god I'm freaking out a little bit And more boys than
one hope some guy doesn't sit here and take a nap my legs
are getting jelly because I'm nervous can someone photoshop
put skin right here right there actually in my
arms where where's my computer oh here thank you Wait, hold
on.
Oh, hold on.
I can't read.
Hold on.
I'm covered in cords.
One second.
Where's my mouse?
Oh, there it is.
Thanks.
I don't know, actually, which ones are showing up, but thank
you.
All right.
Let's go.
I'll be back.
For you.
There's a nerd?
And there's a nerd.
Let's keep going this way.
Jittery physics.
Oh!
There was no other door in here, was there?
Sorry, I forgot.
This one.
Oh, wait!
We have to go down here.
No bad.
the nerd oh wait this way there we go we're on bc connecting
bridge i want to find this is gonna sound so bad oh look at
that wait is this where he goes it's a dud isn't this where
fortune destroys the bridge and he goes a dud did you say no
to absolutely Absolutely.
Well, Fortune was here, right?
Yeah, I think she was on the other side.
What's it like in VR?
Oh my god, it smells so good.
I bet that's Fortune's smell.
But Fortune's making that smell.
Her pheromones for me.
Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
Fortune.
Anyway.
I want to find out.
I want to find, oh sorry, I didn't mean to put you guys in
the wall.
My goal, even though I only have, well I have one hour, one
hour, I want to find, this is going to sound so bad, but I
want to find where Emma gets shot, because it's one of my
favorite shots in the game.
Well, not the, not like, phew, phew, shot, like, viewing
shot, in, anyway, well, she doesn't get shot, she gets
stabbed.
We didn't shoot her, you know what I mean?
Just, uh, oh my god, wait!
It's the bathroom!
Oh my god!
You can even see my thingy!
This is how I'm viewing what I'm doing for you guys.
Oh say, can you see?
By the dungily lines.
God bless America.
Why are...
Wait, wait a second.
Why is she in the girl's bathroom?
Why is she on every star in the girl's bathroom?
Also, guys, I gotta go to the little ghosty's room.
One moment.
Can I actually use the toilet?
No.
Star's taken.
Wonder who's in the men's room?
Let's check it out.
You and me.
I'm going to lift you up just a little bit.
Okay.
You ready?
Follow me.
Oh, wait.
We...
I use the bathroom, you guys.
I have to...
I have to... Wait, hold on.
Sorry, I'm like always trying to adjust it so it's not too
invasive.
I have to use... I have to wash my hands.
Wash your hands, do it.
Hey, hey, hey, hey!
I'm working on it, okay?
Gosh!
Gotta get under my fingernails.
Scrubba-dub-dub.
Scrub-dub-dub.
What songs did they say that you can sing?
four four didn't flush the toilet it's automatic it's
automatic gosh I hear a bomb it's just a bomb up there don't
worry about it it's decorative happy
birthday happy birthday snake eater what a thrill with
darkness and silence through the night what a thrill i'm
searching and i'll melt into you okay let's keep going oh
wait hold on
okay let's go now to the men's room
I'm not supposed to be in there!
Here we go.
What?
There's only two stalls!
Why is there only two?
How much do you want to bet she's in there?
Oh, there she is!
Where she is!
There she is!
Oh, it's the urinals.
Where do you flush?
How do you flush it?
It's automatic?
Are you sure?
Isn't there's no water that comes through at all?
So it just stinks like pee all the time?
There is water.
Oh, okay.
Well, anyway, I'll get out of here.
Stinks.
Let's go down here.
This is the kitchen, right?
Yeah!
Oh!
The orange!
Can I get in?
Can I grab it?
No, I can't interact.
Oh my gosh, the orange!
The orange!
Just hold on, I can still blend in though.
I can still blend in.
Just a box.
just a box too short to use the urinal shut the hell up just
a box nobody would know how would they know nobody would
know how would they know the minto it's
913 we gotta go go go we gotta go find ee and rescue her but
also if they wanted me to if they wanted me to go faster
they shouldn't put such a distracting images on the wall I
feel like this could be edited into a meme you know if I'm
just like hold on I'm just like Wow you know
you could put a picture here wow
okay let's keep going there's also this is where that's over
sorry you can't see it over there let me see if my
controllers my controllers are not so great but I can't
believe that they said that they were charged when they were
at zero percent that's where that's where the bomb guy was
look at all these want you
see her sheesh stillman yeah yeah there Oh, there's even
watermelons here.
Can you go in here?
Oh, wait.
This isn't...
Oh, he was in there.
That's right.
I thought I got the wrong door.
Can we go inside?
Oh, we can!
Not much in here.
Ooh, it is like this.
It looks like you're spying on me.
Stop, you creep.
I love my gross Oji-san Oji.
She was such a freak, and we love her for that.
I'm leaving.
You guys don't understand me.
I think this is the...
Yeah, this is the right way.
Now we're on CD Connecting Bridge.
Does anyone understand you?
I don't know.
No one understands me.
No one gets me.
We gotta go.
Run, run, run.
What's over here?
Oh, this goes down.
Wait.
Wait, did this fall?
Oh god.
they do they fall they fall they fall oh my god
how are you guys feeling are you guys uh motion sick at all
are you guys feeling okay am i moving too fast am i moving
too quickly are we all right
all good not a bit It's perfect.
I'm not motion-sick.
I'm just sick of you.
I'm sick of you!
Okay.
I'm drunk right now.
Don't drink and watch streams.
Alright, let's go through here.
Oh, a surveillance camera.
Oh my gosh, look at it's moving even.
Okay, let's go through here.
Oh, it's dark.
Strat D, sediment pool.
Oh, I hate this area.
I hate this area.
Did I mention I hate this area?
Whoa.
You can see in there, and like the...
There's like...
Hold on, let me see if I can show you guys.
You can see like...
Sorry, at auto levels.
You see like the reflections and stuff from the, I guess the
steam from the water or whatever the hell that is.
Thinks she likes this area.
No!
You need to, oh, you need to learn how to listen.
Don't drop us.
Ooh, ooh, ooh.
One second.
Okay, let's go.
Which way should I go, though?
Actually, I don't remember.
There's this one, and then there's that one.
There's that one over there.
And then there's also the lower levels.
Oh, no way.
I don't remember which way to go.
The nerd is down there.
Nothing here.
But this is MGS fans' dream come true, for real.
Love this for you.
I know it's so fun!
Oh my god, it's so awesome.
I don't remember this particular building.
I don't remember which way it gets us to Emma.
This is, uh...
Level 1.
I can't read.
What's this one?
You're an expert, Minto.
I'm not an expert with...
Oh, Shell 1 to 2!
Wait, can we even get through here, or will it tell us no?
yeah um i think this is where we get the cell phone i think
we have a bit of a problem actually now that i think about
it there's areas all around here that look like where wait a
second i think actually over there that might be it hold on
let me show you guys
because it has the staircase or the ladder right there
right?
Is that it?
Maybe?
That, sorry my sleeves are so big that right there, right?
Pretty sure that's where we went down from and then they
cross through here, right?
But at the same time, here if I show you the other side, it
looks the exact same.
So I'm not quite sure anymore.
Alright guys, I'm gonna have to jump.
But I'm gonna make this jump without you, okay?
I'll bring you over once it's safe.
Here, watch me from afar.
You can do it.
Alright, kid.
I'll see you later.
On the other side.
Ah!
We
did it!
What did you think that I didn't do it?
Come on.
What did you... Why did you... We did it.
We did it.
Come on.
Alright.
Now look at me.
Don't look at me.
I'll turn around.
It's really smoky here, so we gotta be careful, okay?
Wait, actually, how do I get over there?
Oh, well then, I don't want to fall off.
Okay, here we go.
I got it.
We're going to jump through here.
Nice.
Run, run, run.
Oh, oh, oh, holy.
They fell all through.
Don't get peed on.
I think we're safe from...
Do you guys...
Wait.
Can you see it up there the the ship there that's not that's
not the ship that Solidus not ship.
Oh my gosh the the solidus doesn't use a plane though Or is
it the Harrier?
I can't tell is it it is the Harrier?
Yeah, it looks like the Harrier.
Oh my god It's solidus is Harrier Wow I So cool.
There's so many things in this game.
I mean, in this recreation, I guess.
Alright, we gotta jump down.
Okay, very good.
And then, I don't know if you guys...
Oh, you can see it.
Look, it says return to the teleport if you need to go back
up.
Or if you want to go back up.
But not us.
I wonder if I drop from down there if we'll make it.
Do you think?
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, how am I supposed to get over there?
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
We made it.
You can get a better look of it from here, too.
Hi, Sol it is.
I'm eating my gunpowder like a good girl.
Parkour.
Teleport.
Stretch out perimeter.
oh my gosh you can see it even more from here hi solidus hi
solidus wait big shell yeah isn't this awesome oh yeah okay
oh geez you guys uh this one's not looking so good okay i
think i have to be very very careful sorry for the camera
sorry for the camera it doesn't look like that's to me only
to you okay here we go on words uh uh whoa it's like really
broken for you guys right now there we go hug the wall oh
this also is if you want to return nice okay we're going up
shell 2
wait where is um where do we see fat man at i can't remember
gosh i can't wait to play mgs2
beep beep what do you mean beep beep what do you mean what
do you mean beep beep hold on i also gotta fix my camera
stuff again real quick sorry guys i keep turning and it make
and since my um my vr stuff is uh is uh on a cord um right
now it's a little difficult to it's a little i keep turning
and so it makes it harder to move around no what do you mean
beep beep we need the access card put you up even oh maybe
that's too high up put you back a little bit there we go
This is better, right?
Okay.
If I...
Okay, wait, I have a second.
Or not a second.
I have a...
I have an idea.
What if, because you guys are the camera, I just walk
backwards and then you guys tell me what's in there.
What is it?
What do you see?
What's in there?
Do you see anything?
Do you have a second?
darkness?
It's a black hole?
It's the void?
I guess it's a good thing we can't go in there.
If it's all just darkness.
Oh, geez.
Um.
Hold on one second.
Hmm.
Let's just keep going.
I think I see fortune.
Don't lie to me.
Don't get my hopes up.
Shell 2 core.
1 floor.
1st floor.
Air purification room.
Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
Also, you guys can't really see it.
But the floors are so shiny.
Wait.
The president.
I'm coming for you, Mr. President.
Oh, he's not.
He's...
You guys, he's already long gone.
High voltage This is where it comes through Right here
You're a man No, I'm a mint Let's keep going this way And
this This I would like to fondly call Trauma Central
I'm going to do a reenactment I'm going to do a reenactment
of trying to get Emma out of this location.
No, Emma, please!
Get up, Emma!
Just get up!
There she is!
Oh my god, I'm just... I'm gonna have to drag Emma!
I'm gonna have to drag her!
Okay,
okay, they're dead.
Come on, Emma.
Come on.
Oh, my god, there is more.
There's too many, Emma.
I'm sorry!
I gotta get out of here!
Snake, please!
I need your help!
Snake!
I'm going offline!
End scene.
Did you guys like that?
Thank you.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I'm trapped.
Oh, wait.
Whoa.
Thank you.
That's so cute, I can't bear it.
Stop it!
Stop it, stop it.
Okay, let's keep going.
Oh, no, no, no, I just messed up my camera, I'm so sorry.
Okay, uh, like so.
Cinema.
Okay, we'll just go this way.
Then we get to the elevator over here.
and we can go see we can go see wait a second though so we
take Emma back through there let's see what happens if we go
downstairs though call elevator oh nice okay here we go B B1
it's peak Are there any bugs down here?
Oh, they didn't include the bugs!
There's no bugs, actually.
Beep, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Baby Corp, thanks for the gifted.
Thank you!
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Oh.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Wait, how do I swim?
Is there a way to go down?
Oh gosh, you guys.
I don't know if we can go through here.
Okay, hold on.
Uh...
How do I go down?
We managed to avoid drowning!
Oh, bonk!
Come on!
Duck!
I don't think we can go.
Press the left stick down to des-
Uh...
Call the Colonel.
Oh, guys, I tried.
Unless, unless, like, it's jump for some reason.
Oh, wait.
I was in there.
You saw, right?
Okay, hold on.
Take it.
Okay,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
Oh, man.
Ghosts.
Ghost just float, apparently.
I have to use my own arms?
I do?
Ew.
you no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
right
let's get out of here okay wait so we take oh that's kind of
disappointing though I thought for sure we would be able to
go see the room where E is at.
Wait, this way is more comfortable.
Okay, let's go inside.
I hope you guys don't mind just like seeing my back the
whole time.
I figured it's kind of like we're on the journey together,
you know what I mean?
You're just following behind me.
Kind of deal, you know?
Called drinks.
I'm throwing my money in there.
Okay, very good.
It's fine.
Okay, I'm glad.
And then there's some security cameras in here.
Or not.
Never mind.
Wow, now I'm a liar.
So we bring her back through here.
Conscious or unconscious.
So this is where we came from.
And then we were like...
Then we were like, oh, wait, where do we go from here?
All I remember is, is it down?
No, it's not down there.
How do we get to the...
How do we get down there?
I only have 30 minutes left.
What do I do?
Where's Strut L?
Gosh, I wish I had a map.
The door that leads down to oil fence is left maybe.
No, this is the one that uh...
That went boop boop.
Unless we can't get down there.
See.
Well, Strut on the right.
Oh, you're right!
Right here.
And here?
Strut L sewage treatment facility.
Oh, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I remember this, I remember this.
Oh, uh-oh, I might accidentally pin a comment.
Sorry, I'm trying to open this up.
My chat is right here, so that's why.
Oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, where am I?
What is this place?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, you guys can see the outside
world, but I can't.
Hmm?
oh the hatch there it is oh it looks really funky on my oh
what there's a gun oh my god there's the sniper oh it's a
little heavy my bad
and then we listen over here and it's Johnny pooping himself
and then if I shoot over here there's snake wait hold on I
want you guys to see oh my bad one second hmm how can I get
you the full view will you guys protect me if I um okay you
guys I'm giving you the gun if I can pick it up wait hold on
there we go I'm giving you guys the gun.
And you have to shoot down anything that tries to attack me
while I go all the way over to the other side.
It's your response.
It's your duty.
Take it.
I'll see you later.
Soldier.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing, bing.
Oh!
I almost fell in.
I stare at the stars in the scars up above and think what am
I made of?
Am I full of sorrow?
Am I hurt?
When paint all around, I feel with...
AHHHHH!
Right, what's wrong?
Right, right, right!
You guys are supposed to protect me!
You guys are supposed to...
What happened?
Okay, I got one more shot.
I'm believing in you.
Okay, whoo-hoo-hoo.
Um, what am I made of?
Am I full?
Sorry if I get the lyrics wrong, by the way.
I can't really remember.
You know what, I'm gonna go around.
Oh my god, Johnny!
Wait, no, he's at the next one.
Just kidding.
you thought you thought wait you thought you thought there
was Johnny nope I was just kidding hi mom Wow it's so
beautiful from here actually I kind of wish the sky was a
little bit more orange mmm that's so nice over here wish you
were here or am i filled with love i walk down the street oh
oh wait wait a second there's actually something here
there's like a headset here oh my god it reeks oh my god
wait but now i'm not lying there's actually a like uh like
uh what's the word like a pair of headphones a pair of Can I
pick them up?
It doesn't look like it.
Oh my god, Johnny!
Johnny Akiba!
Johnny Akiba Sasaki?
What are you doing here?
Oh my god, not on my stream!
Okay, hi guys!
Hello, can you see me?
Can you see me waving at you?
Wow, it's so beautiful!
Hey guys, don't forget to shoot it if anything comes and
gets me.
Don't forget to shoot.
If anything comes and gets me.
I sure hope no bisexuals come out of the water.
You took the ammo with you.
No, I didn't.
I'm looking in the water.
It looks pretty clear.
I sure hope Oh, that there's no bisexuals in the water Oh,
oh no Oh god Oh, oh Right, what's wrong Right, right So
you guys want to go on Emma simulator Follow me, follow me
Like I said, it's really pretty
Okay Alright, here we go.
You can see the whole place from here.
Oh, don't fall.
Don't fall.
We can take it slow.
I'll show you the headphones that were on the other side and
everything.
Right.
What's wrong?
Rising!
Uh, anyway.
It's harder than it looks, okay, guys?
It's harder, it's, it's, it's harder than it looks, okay?
Takes more balance than you'd realize.
Okay.
And then you come around here, and it's just the vast, vast
ocean.
It's just all ocean.
It's nothing much else.
But I love the ocean.
So I really like this.
Okay, let's keep going.
Watch your step now, let your step.
Okay, good.
Good, good, good, good.
Okay, we're going.
We're going.
We're running.
And jump!
Okay.
See him?
See right there?
It's a pair of headphones.
But I can't pick them up for some reason.
Oh, wait!
Listen!
Freeze!
girl what are you doing here it's not my choice thank you
very much oh you're not gonna shoot me no why not stay away
from good-looking women when you're fighting otherwise
you'll get hit with diarrhea oh one of the few things I
learned from shadow Moses what are you talking about ancient
history don't worry about it I have no idea what you're
talking about but does this mean you're letting me go well
you could have found a nicer way to say that but hurry
thanks don't mention it just run like hell oh no my stomach
oh not again this place is about to sink just get out fast
okay oh my god what what's your name don't have one huh okay
fine it's Johnny Johnny hey if we run into each other again
What a weird guy.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
That was so fun.
Did you guys hear that?
I didn't...
I guess I just didn't...
I didn't lean down far enough before.
Oh my god.
That was so awesome.
The whole thing.
Perfect.
Oh, I'm so glad that we came back then.
we came back then okay careful careful I wish up there
though you could oh wait hold on I wish up there you could
see wait you could see a little cipher going by it's so cute
um wait hold on I'll be very careful to show you where oh
wait no you're all the way out in the ocean I can't grab you
hold on let me go back upstairs give me oh wait there we go
you see it you see it flying around up there a cipher oh
it's gone now chat is the streamer about to cry because she
loves mgs too so much
Why are you gonna call me out like that?
Stop calling me out.
Okay.
Let's keep going.
Hold on.
Let me adjust myself as well.
There we go.
And you.
I
think that should be good.
okay let's go let's go to where she died but i also want to
show you wait can we oh yeah i can grab you from there okay
good good good this is where she dies look how beautiful
hold on have to be very careful come here
wow it's so pretty it's actually so relaxing here.
It's so relaxing.
Any vamp Easter eggs?
I don't think so.
I don't see anything.
There's not even blood here.
It's not even blood.
I think actually she dies down a little bit, like...
Oh, sorry.
I can't grab you.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
I kept trying to grab you, but I can't for some reason.
Well, there we go.
I think actually she dies right before it, right?
But, um...
Like right here.
But there's still no blood or anything.
I say die.
I mean get stabbed.
When she gets attacked.
So that means the next location should be where she actually
dies.
Right?
What time is it?
Oh, I have 10 minutes!
Oh gosh, you guys.
Room 1F.
Cheop.
And we go through here.
And here.
Oh, there's the Zone of the Enders boxes.
What's up here?
Oh, this is where the boxes are.
Just kidding.
Actually, I have no idea where we are now.
Can I get up there?
Hoot!
I don't think so.
There he goes!
Wee!
Well, guys...
Actually, I kind of want to end off in the nice sunset area,
if that's okay.
So we'll go back outside.
we'll go back to the to the dead area
there we go
yay thank you guys for letting me indulge in my um my metal
gear brand rye a little bit just a little bit thanks for the
viewer tour have fun of kai and in japan thank you thank you
for the Thank you, Marilyn.
Thank you.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, I'm gonna unplug my other.
I'm gonna unplug my things now because thank you.
This is pretty good.
Yeah, I had so much fun.
I hope you guys did too.
I know maybe it was, if you don't know Metal Gear, maybe it
was like kind of whatever.
But it was really cool just seeing.
And then up there, up right above is a snake.
Pliskin!
It's Thanks for the stream.
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Um...
But yeah.
Uh...
So I'll be going to off-kai this weekend!
And then right from after off-kai I'll be going to Japan.
Ooh!
But I will be streaming in Japan as much as I can.
Matara and I will be doing every other day.
So she's streaming one day, and then I stream the next day,
and then she's streaming the next day, and...
Well, you know, whatever.
Stream us so much, been aapo, and a afkai!
thank you thank you thank you for the tour the facilities
can't wait to see when you come back thank you so much thank
you I'll miss you guys because I won't be able to see you
guys so much since I'll be in Japan but we'll have so many
stories and so many things to tell you about so I'm very
excited for that as well hmm hmm and also whatever we're
cooking while we're there hmm hmm one what that could be and
then of course thank you scufford for making this fun low
poly model for me and um yeah i didn't expect to take so
much time here at the big shell but it was fine we went to
mcdonald's we went to that rental wait like it was like mid
cafe rental girl cafe fake me thanks for the hunko super
thank you thank you and um yeah so you guys take care of
yourself while um i'm gone as well i'm gonna move you
downwards a little to my level and um yeah looking forward
to it thank you thank you now i actually have to get to my
meeting in 10 minutes that is a legit and real meeting i i i
Where are you guys?
I'm back.
Don't worry.
My very real, my very real meeting that I have to go to that
is not fake meeting.
It's real.
And I remember when it is.
It's in seven minutes.
Enjoy Afkaya and Japan.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
And, um...
Um...
I don't know what else to say.
Be good wisps.
Okay.
Be good wisps while I'm gone, since I won't see you as much.
But I will still be seeing you.
Just not as much.
And, um...
Thank you!
I'm a...
I'm a simp.
and um i don't know what else to say sorry this is weird i
don't know how to end these kinds of things because i'm like
so wiggly wiggly wiggly so um
uh can you end the stream that way you got it wait there we
go you got it bye everyone bye bye bye bye bye bye see you
when i get back or if i'm or If I see you at off guide, see
you there!
See you there, see you there, see you there, see you there.
Bye-bye!
Wait,
do you guys want to watch me fall?
Right.